first the husband and then the wife
double gold glory in the track cycling
for a british couple on paralympics gb's
most successful day of tokyo 2020 so far
it's quite a
while before we actually managed to come
together and hug each other because you
kind of been shepherded around different
parts of the village for ceremonies for
anti-doping and things but that moment
we finally got to hug and laura burst
into tears which made me cry a little
bit after that i never cried by the way
so
the team's third win of the day in the
izu velodrome came in the last track
event of the games after a dramatic
final lap in the mixed team sprint
i even kind of give it a really big
lunge at the end because i knew it was
going to be close um so when i came
around and saw that we got a number one
next-door name and the world record as
well it was like wow we've we've pulled
something out of the bag there
for mickey yule bronze in the power
lifting comes 11 years after he lost
both legs serving in afghanistan
inspired by the sporting successes he
witnessed at london 2012. i found great
sort of encouragement i could still be a
sportsman i could still push myself i
could still maybe prove people wrong and
get back to the guy i used to be in
i'm definitely a legacy from london
in the pool maisie summers newton swam
to victory in the 100 meters
breaststroke making her a double
paralympic champion at the age of just
19.
and there was a win too in the mixed
four by 100 meter freestyle
the athletics track also brought glory
for british sprinters sophie hahn and
thomas young
the latest successes put paralympics gb
second overall behind china with the
prospects of many more medals to come
emma birchley sky news